[Applaus]
[Musik]
kennt ihr ein land in dem es praktisch
keinen lehrer sie die bürokratie gibt wo
die steuererklärung mit ein paar wenigen
klicks in minuten erledigt ist oder
zugang zum internet ein grundrecht
darstellt wo man firmen in ein paar
minuten gründen kann und wo man mit
behörden fast nur online kommuniziert
über dieses wunderland der bürokratie
hasser sprechen wir heute meine lieben
visuelle politik zuschauer es nennt sich
estland und ist sogar teil der
bürokratischen verzeihung der
europäischen union ganz genau heute
werden wir ganz wenig über probleme
sprechen unsere stattdessen jede menge
lösungen vorstellen schließlich haben
wir euch ja vor rund einer woche in
unserem bundeswehr video ein
gigantisches negativbeispiel für
zerstörung durch übermäßig und
fehlgeleitete bürokratie präsentiert wir
haben auch darüber gesprochen welche
grundsätzlichen gesetzmäßigkeiten was
die jede 1 volk reiche staatsverwaltung
irgendwann in den selbstzerstörungs
modus führen ja wir haben jede menge
schlechte laune verbreitet und es war
sogar vom horror des point of no return
die rede aber ich habe euch damals auch
versprochen dass ihr euch mit der
düstere diagnose für deutschland nicht
alleine lassen dass wir euch auf all die
bedrückenden fragen auch antworten
liefern werden und heute fangen wir
damit an also haltet euch gut fest denn
bei all dem dass euch in diesem video
über island erzählen werden könnte schon
die spucke wegbleiben aber eines nach
dem anderen schon beim steuersystem
fängt ist nämlich an schaut her
estland hat das wettbewerbsfähigste
steuersystem in der oecd so die tags
foundation ein think tank der sich mit
der steuer und ausgabenpolitik von
regierungen befasst oder das hier
steuererklärung und in estland ein blick
ein klick fertig okay vielleicht denkt
er jetzt sind das steuersystem niedrige
steuersätze kaum störende bürokratie
estland muss ein steuerparadies sein so
etwas wie die cayman islands der ostsee
aber nein es ist ganz anders die
unternehmenssteuern betragen estland 20
prozent der persönliche
einkommensteuersatz liegt ebenfalls bei
20 prozent das sind keine änderung hohen
steuersätze aber auch keine die auf
mauritius oder in liechtenstein und
obwohl island über keine dumping
steuersatz verfügt ist es ihm gelungen
viele unternehmen aus der it-branche
anzuziehen und es ist der geburtsort
weltweit erfolgreicher start aus wie
etwa skype auch andere global
erfolgreiche unternehmen wie
transformers oder bolt haben ihren
ursprung in estland oder deren software
ist von entwicklern geschaffen worden
neben den steuern haben die ersten
nämlich auf eine andere sehr originelle
strategie um unternehmen und talente
anzuziehen die elektronische residenz
oder residenz das heißt jeder mensch
kann eine art virtueller bürger dieses
landes werden es reicht dazu einfach
online ein formular auszufüllen und
natürlich seine identität nachzuweisen
[Musik]
wir haben darüber schon einmal ein video
gemacht was ich euch an dieser stelle
natürlich verlinken damals hatten sich
nur ein paar leute für diese
elektronische residenz beworben ist gibt
es aber mehr als 70.000 aller bürger und
sogar der papst ist dabei und einige
werden sich vielleicht die frage stellen
wie sieht es in estland denn mit der
lebensqualität aus werden dort
vielleicht öffentliche dienstleistungen
zugunsten der wirtschaft geopfert gibt
es dort auch so etwas wie einem
sozialstaat in die antwort lautet ja wie
fast alle europäischen länder hat
estland ein solides sozialsystem
öffentliche gesundheitsversorgung
hochwertige staatliche
bildungseinrichtungen und öffentlichen
nahverkehr
und nicht nur das das hessische
bildungssystem ist eines der besten der
welt
[Musik]
laut dem bericht ist programm von
international student assessment auch
bekannt als pisa steht estland auf der
liste der länder mit der besten bildung
an vierter stelle und übertrifft damit
sogar das sonst so hochgelobte finnland
darüber haben wir übrigens auch schon
ein video gemacht außerdem sind
dienstleistungen wie der öffentliche
nahverkehr für die staatsbürger
kostenlos zumindest in der hauptstadt
tallinn und den meisten regionen des
landes aber klingt das alles zu gut um
wahr zu sein wie der wahr gewordene
europäische traum wie haben die ersten
das alles nur hinbekommen sind sie
insgeheim etwas superreichen baltischen
bernstein scheiß und können sich deshalb
das alles leisten nun ganz und gar nicht
estland ist kein land der millionäre im
gegenteil bis in den 1990 er jahre war
es teil des sowjet union muss noch vor
30 jahren kämpfte das land nicht nur
darum den anschluss an den besten zu
finden dann lebte auch unter der
ständigen bedrohung einer russischen
invasion es hätte den ersten zumindest
vor dem beitritt zur nato dasselbe
passieren können die beute der ukraine
aber im gegensatz zur ukraine oder
litauen estland ein wahres erfolgsmodell
wegen des wirtschaftswachstums nannte
man estland einen baltischen tiger staat
es ist fest in eu und nato integriert
hat eine vortragende bildungssystem es
gilt als ein stabiles und erfolgreiches
land nur in vielen bereichen noch ein
ganzes stück besser mit fast keine
bürokratie und den effizientesten
steuersystem der welt nach diesem video
werdet ihr verstehen wie die ist es
geschafft haben das bei das steuersystem
der welt in dem effizientesten staat
aufzubauen also macht euch bereit für
diese spannende wie lehrreiche reise ins
baltikum in ein land von dem sich alle
ein gutes stück absteigen können wie
immer beginnen wir mit einem blick in
die geschichte denn schon dieser zeigt
wie erstaunlicher weg der iss ist
[Musik]
der sprung des baltischen tigers unserer
geschichte beginnt im jahr 1996 damals
hätten nur wenige auf die zukunft des
landes gewettet denn wirtschaftlich
befand sich island in der tat auf dritte
welt niveau viele menschen hatten keine
arbeit viele wanderten aus vor allem
fachkräfte
das land mit 20 mitten im umbruch seit
1991 von der sowjetunion unabhängig
wurde und macht eine wahre ökonomische
schocktherapie durch während einer
wahnsinnig kurzen zeitspanne schaffte es
den exit aus dem maroden systems
sozialistischer planwirtschaft und
sprang kopfüber in den großen weiten
ozean der marktwirtschaft innerhalb
weniger jahre wurden fast alle
öffentlichen unternehmen privatisiert
und die preise dereguliert dies bedeutet
zunächst hohe kosten für die menschen
vor allem für diejenigen die nur wenig
verdienten und wer arbeitslos war hatte
ganz schlechte karten natürlich redete
damals anfang der 90er jahre noch keiner
davon dass so ein ding namens internet
einmal wirtschaftlichen wohlstand
bringen könnte anders als im falle der
ddr stand kein reiches land wie
westdeutschland bereit dass die marode
wirtschaft hätte übernehmen und aufwand
können oder gar durch sozialtransfers
den wirtschaftlichen abschluss der
bürger dämpfen würde kurz gesagt die
pisten dieses ganz ganz dreckig und dann
kam 1996 dieser er mit der fliege den
ihr auf dem bildschirm sieht thomas
hendrik elvis er war von 93 96 ist
botschafter in den usa kanada und mexiko
und er sagte folgendes
etwas was man denken in bezug auf island
geprägt hat war die idee dass der unsere
jungen leute dazu bringen sollten mit
computern zu arbeiten unter elvis
einfluss wurde die tigersprung strategie
geboren worum genau es dabei ging nur in
mitte der neunziger jahre war immerhin
doch schon ein wenig zu erkennen dass
der menschheit mit den internet eine
revolution bevorstehen könnte deren
chancen zu erkunden durchaus lohnenswert
sind damals in einer zeit als der
deutsche kanzler helmut kohl doch allen
ernstes dachte datenautobahnen seinen
straßenbauprojekte welche in die
zuständigkeit der
landesverkehrsministerium fiel und damit
der aufmerksamkeit eines bundeskanzlers
nicht würdig waren die ethischen
politiker bereits voll im bilde sie
ergriffen die gelegenheit beim schopf
und prescht in sachen internet voran
[Musik]
als harris aus den vereinigten staaten
kam um 9 96 außenminister von russland
zu werden stellte die regierung computer
und internet über alles andere innerhalb
weniger jahre hatten alle ist ischen
schulen computer die regierung
organisierte alle möglichen kampagnen um
die bürger im umgang mit der neuen
technologie zu schulen im jahr 2005 war
ist und das erste land der welt das
wahlen mit elektronischer stimmabgabe
über das internet durch führte aber
bereits im jahr 2000 er kannte das
estnische parlament internetzugang als
ein garantiertes grundrecht an all diese
maßnahmen brachten auch ganz schnell
ergebnisse die studenten die mit
computern und allem was dazugehört
aufwuchsen waren genau jene die das
internet startups made in estonia
gründet doch was wie ein goldenes
zeitalter des aufbruchs in eine neue
welt klingt hatte auch schattenseiten
für diese sorgt dass vor allem der stets
missgelaunten nachbar im osten
russland beschuldigt einen cyberkrieg in
hessen zu haben um island auszuschalten
estland war in vielerlei hinsicht wenn
er eben auch als opfer von cyber
attacken der erste bekannte und
umfassende cyber angriff auf einen start
fand dort im jahr 2007 statt und die
auswirkungen waren heftig ins wie jenem
zeitpunkt war praktisch die gesamte
technische verwaltung bereits
digitalisiert als folge war das ganze
land für einige tage lahmgelegt auch
krankenhäuser doch die schlauesten haben
daraus gelernt und das land engagiert
sich aktiv für cyber sicherheit vor
allem in zusammenarbeit mit seinen nato
partner angesichts dieser geballten
kompetenz war es also keine große
überraschung dass die hauptstadt tallinn
mit im jahr 2007 auf den zuschlag für
die gründung des hauptquartiers der nato
für cybersicherheit erhielt aber auch
dieses konnte das baltische land nicht
von einer anderen noch größeren
bedrohung schützen denn ganz dicke kam
es ein jahr nach putins hacker angriff
in der finanzkrise von 2008 wurden die
ersten so gebeutelt wie kaum ein anderes
land während das bip der usa im
schlimmsten jahr der finanzkrise rund
acht prozent zurückging waren es bei
über 14 prozent mit anderen worten das
ganze land in den bach runter und in
diesem moment der existenziellen krise
stand die regierung vor einem dilemma
erhöhen wir die steuern lassen wir uns
von europa aus apache helfen oder wänden
der eine extreme sparpolitik und man
entschied sich fürs sparen austerität so
der fachbegriff und man sparte nicht zu
knapp um euch eine vorstellung zu geben
und dann liest ganz einfach über 30
prozent der beamten man setzte
staatliche investitionen fast
vollständig aus die einschnitte waren
gewaltig und für vieles sehr schmerzhaft
aber die steuern würden nicht erhöht
sogar leicht gesenkt und ihr fragt euch
jetzt vielleicht hat diese politik
funktioniert nun urteilt am besten
selbst
[Musik]
hier seht ihr das kaufkraftbereinigt pro
kopf bip es die nur 30 jahren hat
estland griechenland und portugal
überholt und holt sogar zu spanien auf
das ist ein echtes wunder wenn man
bedenkt wo man in den neunzigerjahren
standorte liegt die arbeitslosigkeit in
island oder gerade mal 5,5 prozent aus
der folgen der korona partie wie die
brennende frage lautet also wie haben
die esten das alles geschafft was ist
ihre zauberformel reicht es wirklich aus
die digitalisierung voranzutreiben und
alles ist paletti nun das schauen wir
uns jetzt mal genauer an
das wettbewerbsfähigste steuersystem der
welt habt ihr euch schon mal gefragt wie
eigentlich ein effizientes steuersystem
aussehen sollte nun zunächst einmal gibt
es eine rangliste die von der
amerikanischen denkfabrik text
foundation erstellt wurde solch eine
ranking mag vielleicht angreifbar und
interpretationssache seien aber wichtig
ist das wetter das fähig nicht unbedingt
niedrige steuersätze bedeutet denn es
geht auch darum auf welche weise steuern
erhoben und gezahlt werden schon im wort
steuern steckt ja das werk steuern es
geht also darum wohin der staat mit
seinem steuersystem die bürger
hinsteuert ob in den abgrund oder in die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit
aber was genau an seinem stopp system
macht ist man nun eigentlich derart
konkurrenzfähig nur zuallererst ist das
steuersystem ganz einfach aufgebaut wir
können fast alle steuern ist mit einer
zahl zusammenfassen 20 und zwar 20
prozent einkommenssteuer 20 prozent
mehrwertsteuer und 20 prozent
körperschaftssteuer einfach und
überschaubar bei der einkommensteuer
gibt es ein paar ausnahmen für niedrige
einkommen und das gehalt eines ersten zb
weniger als 6000 euro pro jahr beträgt
zahlt man keine steuern das ist quasi
der grundfreibetrag in der spanne von
6000 bis 25.200 euro gelten ermäßigte
sätze laber 25.200 euro zahlt jeder
genau den gleichen anteil von 20% es
gibt auch keinerlei steuerliche vorteile
für bestimmte ausgaben oder
investitionen das steuerwesen ist also
nicht nur einfach sondern auch neutrale
neutral heisst in diesem zusammenhang es
dient nur dazu einnahmen für den staat
zu erzielen nicht dazu bestimmte
verhaltensweisen von verbrauchern oder
investoren zu fördern oder zu bestrafen
der staat vertraut also vor allem seinen
bürgern dass sie sich selbst gut steuern
können und er keine komplizierte
steuerungsfunktion ins steuersystem
einbauen muss ganz anders zb in
deutschland an steuervorteile bei
richter renten oder bausparen ein
wirrwarr von absetzung möglichkeiten und
absetzung grenzen für werbungskosten
oder haushaltsnahe dienstleistungen oder
die unterschiedliche besteuerung von
gewinnen aus aktien und aus
immobilienverkäufen wenn man die
immobilie zehn jahre lang gehalten hat
in deutschland steuern eben nicht nur
tragen und im ergebnis ist das
steuersystem ein wirrwarr aus regeln und
ausnahmen die oft experten verstehen
kein wunder dass in deutschland ein
ganzer riesiger berufsstand die
steuerberater von diesen chaos lebt die
größte ungerechtigkeit ist dabei jedoch
dass in einem komplex steuer lang beach
germany nur eine kleine gilt elite die
sich die besten steuerberater leisten
kann überhaupt von all den
vergünstigungen des staates profitieren
kann und der große rest kommt für diese
vorteile dann durch um so höhere steuern
auf in island hingegen ist steuerberater
ein eher seltener beruf wobei dies nur
die spitze des eisbergs ist der wohl
größte vorteil liegt darin dass ein
staat mit seiner systemische bedingten
inkompetenz keine unnötigen verzerrung
des marktes
denkt mal darüber nach nicht neutrale
steuersysteme schaffen anreize für eine
bestimmte art von investitionen
gegenüber einer anderen die folge es
könnte sein dass eine person aus rein
steuerlichen gründen in unternehmen
investiert nicht jedoch in unternehmen b
in estland unterlässt ist der staat eine
bestimmte investitionen zu fördern erst
einen doppelten vorteil das system ist
nicht nur gerecht sondern überlässt die
investitionsentscheidungen auch jeder
die sie am qualifiziertesten treffen
können denjenigen die mit ihrem eigenen
geld haften das zu schweigen von den
gewaltigen einsparungen an geld und zeit
die dann in wirklich produktive und
kreative dinge schließen können das
einreichen einer steuererklärung ist
dann ist so einfach dass es nur fünf
minuten dauert und das ist keine
übertreibung
[Musik]
dass ihr hier seht ist eine anleitung
der estnischen regierung die man eine
steuererklärung abgibt den link zum
vollständigen video findet ihr in der
beschreibung reden hier über einen
vorgang der buchstäblich in fünf minuten
und 13 sekunden erledigt werden kann und
warum geht alles so schnell nun alle
daten sind schon digital gespeichert die
behörden und der steuerzahlende bürger
haben wollen zugang gast transparenz ist
das oberste prinzip des indischen
staates wohlgemerkt die transparenz der
verwaltung gegenüber den bürgern nicht
umgekehrt im prinzip muss der erste nur
klicken und seine einer und außen oder
kapitalanlagen bestätigen ganz einfach
und übersichtlich ohne unwägbarkeiten
und ohne böse überraschungen nur falls
ein nächste noch nicht erfasste
einnahmen oder kapitalerträge aus dem
ausland hat müsste er diese
logischerweise noch ergänzen und dann
wäre auch die estnische steuererklärung
länger und aufwendiger aber auch hierbei
würde das ganze noch immer viel
schneller erledigt werden als in der
druck- raten republik deutschland also
wäre das noch nicht genug gibt es noch
einen weiteren super vorteil in estlands
steuersystem die körperschaftssteuer die
liegt bei einem satz von 20 prozent aber
ist das jetzt viel oder eher wenig nur
das kommt auf den vergleich an in
spanien liegt er zwischen 20 und 25
prozent je nach größe des unternehmens
in deutschland sind es 30 prozent der
hessische vorteil liegt also gar nicht
mal darin dass der steuersatz viel
niedriger wäre sondern darin wie diese
steuer gezahlt wird denn zunächst einmal
wird wird das geld besteuert dass man
aus dem unternehmen heraus sind im falle
von testierung also denn die der anlage
bzw investitionen im unternehmen
entfällt ganz einfach die steuern
außerdem gibt es keine steuern auf
dividenden wodurch eine
doppelbesteuerung vermieden wird und
außerdem können estnische unternehmen
verluste aus früheren jahren mit
gewinnen aus anderen jahren verrichten
das gibt es zwar auch so ähnlich in
deutschland nur jedoch ihr art ist
bereits komplizierte und mit strengen
obergrenzen den unternehmen oft
kopfzerbrechen bereiten und langfristige
investitionen behindert und noch einmal
sowohl das einrichten von steuern als
auch die gründung eines unternehmens in
diesem land sind so einfach wie das
einrichten eines facebook kontos
diese bilder stammen aus einem anderen
tutorial das zeigt wie man in estland
unternehmen gründet man braucht dazu die
schon erwähnte ti residenz und dann
dauert es nur drei minuten okay ihr seht
das alles klingt super toll einfache
steuern relativ niedrige steuersätze
aber wo ist da der harten was haben die
esten gehofft worden ist so günstige
steuern zu haben nun die antwort lautet
nicht okay aber die kann das überhaupt
sein keine angst denn jetzt erklären sie
es euch im detail
die strategie der neue bürokratie island
hatte ganz normalen sozialstaat mit
ordentlichem öffentlichen gesundheits
und bildungswesen guten straßen und
einem so gut wie kostenlosen öl plv in
vielerlei hinsicht ist der ethnische
sozialstaat noch besser als in anderen
eu-ländern wie gesagt ist der
öffentliche nahverkehr fast kostenlos
das bildungssystem spitzenklasse und das
schafften die esten alles bei einer
staatsverschuldung von rund 18 prozent
ihres bip zum vergleich der europäische
durchschnitt wer sich bereits 100 groß
hält wie geht das also bei solch relativ
niedrigen steuern nun die antwort lautet
effizienz und minimalismus die esten
erreichen dieselben und teilweise sogar
noch bessere ergebnisse mit viel weniger
aufwand in estland ist quasi eine
revolution im gange eine art revolution
der verwaltung
doch über diesen wandel wird selten in
den medien gesprochen aber weil wir so
an politik erfahrt ihr was genau es
damit auf sich hat im jahr 2013 trat das
neue gesetz über den öffentlichen dienst
in kraft so sollen zum beispiel die
einstellungs regel für beamte reformiert
und zwar dezentral von nun an menschen
jedes amt selbst wie viel mitarbeiter
man braucht vom staat vorgegeben ist
hierbei nur ein ziel es soll
sichergestellt sein dass der anteil der
beamten an der gesamtbelegschaft 12
prozent nicht übersteigt das prinzip
heißt null bürokratie jede art
überschüssiger bürokratie soll wirklich
restlos abgebaut werden und wären zum
beispiel in deutschland dauernd über
alles lieben bürokratie irrsinn geklagt
wird aber dann nichts besser sondern
immer nur schlimmer wird ziehen die
ersten den bürokratieabbau konsequenz
durch und das auch noch mit erfolg nun
im jahr 2015 führte die regierung zwei
umfragen durch eine bei den unternehmern
des landes und eine weitere bei den
staatsbediensteten mann fragte nach
vorschlägen wie man bürokratie abbauen
könnte mit anderen worten die beamten
selbst halten dabei die verwaltung zu
entlasten
[Musik]
dank dieser umfrage entdeckte estland
zum beispiel dass der regierungsbehörden
14 verschiedene software programme für
die buchhaltung verwendeten das führte
natürlich zu einer menge doppelarbeit
also einigte man sich und wählte eine
einzige software ähnlich verhält es sich
mit der gemeinsamen nutzung von
informationen über die bürger des landes
alle steuerinformationen der einwohner
werden den einen einzigen system
zentralisiert genannt ex rot das
programm verbindet alle
regierungsbehörden banken und alle arten
von finanzinstituten miteinander das
macht zb die aufdeckung von steuerbetrug
viel effektiver die banken teilen die
steuerinformationen ihrer kunden mit der
regierung in echtzeit sind alle infos
verfügbar und weil es so einfach ist und
alle informationen jederzeit bereits
vorhanden sind werden 95 prozent aller
estnischen steuererklärung online
erledigt und zwar so einfach und schnell
wie wir es vorhin gezeigt haben für die
untersuchung und aufdeckung von
steuerbetrugs fällen braucht es keine
aufwändigen behörden anfragen und
tausende menschen die rechnungen dürfen
alles wird digital und mit viel weniger
personal erledigt aber wartet einen
moment wenn das ist noch nicht alles
auch eine digitale minimal verwaltung
braucht der weiterbildung wie das
erlernen neuer methoden und das umlernen
wegen software updates wie organisiert
man das also in estland nun ja man
schuld nur die mittleren führungskräfte
in den ämtern und das reicht diese
tragen das wissen dann an ihre
untergebenen weiter und zwar so intensiv
und umfassend wie sie es vor ort für
nötig halten die folge keine aufwändige
schulungen die das gesamte personal
binden und viel weniger personalbedarf
für die gleichen öffentlichen
dienstleistungen als in vergleichbaren
ländern um euch eine vorstellung zu
geben allein zwischen 2015 und 2017 hat
ist laut 2300 stellen im öffentlichen
dienst abgebaut das scheint auf den
ersten blick keine große zu sein aber
wir reden hier über ein land mit nur
einer million einwohnern und rund
116.000 staatsbediensteten während
beamte entlassen ist dann ganz normal
ist ist eine solche praxis in vielen
anderen eu-ländern gänzlich unbekannt
dafür ist der deutsche ausdruck
verbeamtet wahrscheinlich umgekehrt in
estland ein fremdwort hier kommt
außerdem die äußerst dynamische
wirtschaft ins spiel in der fast
vollbeschäftigung herrscht mit anderen
worten es ist wirklich ein auch einen
guten job zu finden und ist sogar ganz
normal dass jemand privates unternehmen
verlässt und in einem öffentlichen
unternehmen oder einer behörde zu
arbeiten und umgekehrt der damit
einhergehende erfahrungs und
wissenstransfer zwischen
privatwirtschaft und staatlicher schwere
sorgt nicht nur für mehr kompetenz
praxisbezug und empathie in den
amtsstuben sondern erlaubt es den ästen
ihre karriere optimal und flexibel zu
gestalten ohne angst vor abstrichen
durch einen wechsel haben zu müssen
natürlich ist dieses system auch nicht
perfekt
und man muss zugeben dass vieles in
ethische steuer und staatswesen aus der
not heraus geboren wurde island hat zum
beispiel bis heute ein problem damit die
junge fachkräfte ins land zu locken und
die gesellschaft ist hoffnungslos
überaltert
um also nicht vollends in die demokratie
falle zu tappen musste sich ist und so
einiges einfallen lassen um attraktiv
auf fachkräfte aus dem ausland zu wirken
und um die eigenen jungen leute im land
zu halten aber dieses problem ist bis
heute nicht überwunden und leider hat
derzeit auch die inflation an dem land
fast 22 prozent sind es derzeit auch die
russen sind eine herausforderung und
zwar nicht nur jene hinter der grenze
dann auch die russischen minderheit im
eigenen land die fast 25 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung ausmacht wir haben
über diese problematik bereits in einem
anderen video gesprochen dass ich euch
verlinken werde sicherheitspolitisch
gesehen stichwort krieg in der ukraine
ist estland ein äußerst heißes pflaster
im neuen kalten krieg aber auf jeden
fall hat ist das gezeigt wie man ein
modernes und attraktives stars und
steuerwesen aufbaut das den eigenen
bürger start entgegen kommt und jetzt
die frage an euch glaubt dir dass das
englische modell einfach auf andere
länder übertragbar ist was machen die
verwaltungen in anderen ländern falsch
welche veränderungen wären in eurem land
nötig damit die lektion aus estland
angewandt werden können wie immer sind
wir auf eure kommentare und diskussionen
schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video etwas gebracht hat falls ja
geht uns mit einem leid und teils auch
fleißig mit euren freunden vergesst
bitte dich das abo und das glücklich nun
keines unserer künftigen videos nicht
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch
finanziell dieses projekt weiterzuführen
in paper link dazu findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter dem video was gut und
bis bald
[Musik]